hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm gonna be talking about
how i would invest 30 000 pounds in buy
to let property in the uk so if you've
got 30 000 pounds right now in the bank
and you're wanting to put it into buy to
let property this is the video i'm going
to explain exactly how i would do that
and how i would maximize my 30 000
pounds stretch it as far as it's go and
make as much return as possible so the
first thing i want to say is this
property prices are going up a lot if
you're living in london right now you
might be thinking you know i've only got
30 grand that's nowhere near enough to
buy a property but the thing is maybe
you're right if you're looking at buying
a property in london
but when you buy a property as an
investment it's that it's an investment
it's not a home you're not living in it
yourself so it doesn't actually really
matter where it is too much as long as
it's giving you good income as long as
it's giving you good capital
appreciation it doesn't matter where it
is too much someone said to me recently
they said that they were looking to buy
a property i said where are you looking
they said bristol i said why bristol and
they said because that's where i live
and to me it doesn't make much sense
because i've got okay dozens and dozens
of properties all over the place but i
don't manage them myself if i was having
to manage every property that i owned i
would be i would have a full-time job
being a property manager every property
that i have is managed by somebody it's
systemized and that way it gives me
passive income so you want to be
investing i actually i would challenge
you and say this buy deliberately two
hours away from your house because that
way you'll be forced to have to set a
management system in place that you
can't necessarily keep going there and
then when you've got those systems in
place you can go skiing you can go on
holiday you can do what you want because
you've got the systems in place so with
that being said
first place i'm going to jump on i'm
going to go into a little website called
right move right move is the biggest
online there we go uk is number one
where properties are sold and rented
online so i'm gonna i'm gonna type in
let's do birmingham let's try birmingham
which is where i am from and where i
built up a large portfolio back 10 years
or so ago but i'm gonna do 40 miles i
don't really care where it is okay i'm
going to do
70 grand
up to
140 grand now if you're buying a house
for 70 grand or 100 like if you want to
have let's say 100 grand you're only
going to need a deposit of 25
so straight away if you're thinking i've
only got 30 grand a lot of people say
there's no houses of less than 140 grand
well let's find out 70 to 140 let's do
two bed let's look for houses only not
apartments or bungalows not land or
commercial let's do houses
and let's see what we got what we've got
going so we've got seven there we go
it's meant to be it's god's number
777 results just waiting for you and
this is just within 40 miles of
birmingham now an interesting thing i
like to do is i like to see how many
properties have also just recently sold
so if you include the under offer or
just sold subject to contract that will
go up a little bit so that's going to go
up to
3
300. that means that there's literally
almost three thousand properties in that
radius
that have just sold these last few weeks
that means that the market is popping
that means that the the area is trending
so let's see what we've got we're not
gonna search from highest price let's do
let's search from lowest and see if
there's anything for 70 000 pounds
unfortunately on rightmove there's no
way to get rid of the auction properties
so a lot of these properties like for
instance this one in coventry this is an
auction property so you can see look it
says it's on for it's on for 70 grand
but it's actually been sold for 110
because it's an auction property so
if it's an auction property we're gonna
skip it let's see this one this is in
stoke on trent hanley
the condition is
not amazing it looks nice they've got a
beautiful sky in the background to make
the property look a little bit less [ __ ]
so
it looks like it's in decent condition
the kitchen looks
okay it probably needs maybe some new
carpets
the walls probably need painting but
they're actually in good condition so
this is a decent property in decent
condition um
nice little garden area
maybe you could even potentially put
some grass down if you wanted to
although i'd suggest if it's an
investment property don't do that
because the less maintenance the better
at the moment
this garden is very low maintenance so
if the tenants move out and they've left
the grass to grow and you haven't got to
solve it because it's low maintenance
so here we go hanley
i used to actually give out pizzas to
people in hanoi i used to go out in
early nights at the street and find
drunk people um and and give them pizzas
and chat to them and
anyway that was a long time ago
now i just give people property golden
nuggets okay here we go hanley so right
now hanley center it's on the market for
70 000 it's in denbigh street
now again let's let's assume for a
moment you've only got 30 000 pounds so
if you've got 30 000 pounds do you know
what i'm thinking about this property
i'm getting a bit excited now because
you could rent this property out
potentially
oh my goodness as a multi-let property
you could rent this out as a room by
room property which means you could rent
this room out this room out this room
out and this room you would turn into a
bedroom how do you turn a reception room
into a bedroom you put a bed in it so
you could potentially get four lots of
rents
on this property potentially
that room might be a little bit too
small so you might have to potentially
be creative and have a little re-jig
but even if you couldn't
let's say that we're not going to rent
this out room by room we're just going
to rent this out as a straightforward
buy to let how much rent would you get
for this property and how much would it
cost you to buy it
so let's find out how much we it would
cost us to buy it to begin with so we
bought it says offers over 70 000. so
let's assume that we bought it for 70
thousand if we bought that property for
70 000
we would have to
we'd buy the house
for 70 000 pounds
we'd have to put down a deposit of 25
so 25 that's just going to be strictly
a deposit
which is going to be
25
17 and a half grand
so 17 and a half grand is all you're
going to need
as a deposit as a deposit to buy the
house assuming that you got a mortgage
for 475 which is very very very standard
so your deposit
is seventeen thousand five hundred you
that's your deposit your mortgage is
gonna be seventy thousand
times seventy five percent
which is fifty two thousand five hundred
so your mortgage is 50 to
500. now you might think but would i get
a mortgage
what happens if if no one would lend to
me here's the really cool thing
when you buy a house to live in if
you're buying a house to live and we
call that a residential mortgage
getting a residential mortgage is really
tricky because if you're buying a house
and trying to get a residential mortgage
the lenders need to know that you
can pay back that mortgage so they're
going to want to know what do you earn
what's your credit what should this and
they're going to ask you a million
questions to check that you can afford
it however with buy to let properties
they don't really care what you earn
even if you're making 10 grand a year if
you want
minimum minimum minimum wage right they
don't care because what they care about
is they care about can you afford to pay
that mortgage with the rent so they
don't care about your salary they care
about the rents so the mortgage is 52
and a half the rent on a property like
that interest rates are around about two
and a half percent at the moment so if
your mortgage is fifty two and a half
thousand you're going to pay 2.5 percent
you're going to pay 1312
pounds per year as the interest payments
divide that by 12 because you paid
monthly is 109. so you're gonna pay 109
pounds a month on the mortgage for this
house now if you're paying 109 pounds a
month on the mortgage the next question
is well what's the rent so let's figure
out what the rent is so we've got the
full postcode here
st15ja so if we go back to rightmove
but this time
i'm going to search
rent
properties for rent let's see what's
going down with the area
include let and again we're looking for
houses
and this feels quite a big house this is
a three bed house
with two reception rooms and a little
garden so if we're looking for three bed
houses
in that same postcode within quarter of
a mile there's only one result
but this has been agreed this is 750
pounds per month now to be fair the
house does look a little bit nicer so
i'd have to do a little bit more
research but let's assume that we could
rent our property out for just 600
pounds a month which i think is very
very very basic and that's assuming that
you don't rent it out room by room i
mean jeez if you rent it out room by
room
in hanley stoke on trent and by the way
this property was just the first
property that i found like spanx like
this isn't isn't the case of oh i found
this great deal if i type in hanley
which is the specific part of
stoke-on-trent that the property is and
we look for flatmates how much are
people looking to pay rent 300 pounds
for a single or double room
650 for a room 500 these are these are
like new today people looking in hanley
look
looking for a house share looking for a
so like you could potentially get way
more rent if you were really creative
but let's just assume that you rent this
property out as a basic buy to that for
600 pounds a month well what are the
maths gonna look like for you
well you're going to pay 110 pounds a
month on the mortgage
you're gonna rent it out for 600.
that means you're left with 490 pounds a
month to pay with now of that 490 pounds
a month you're gonna have to pay
insurance which is about 20 pounds a
month
so minus 20 pounds you have to pay
someone to manage the property which is
probably going to be about 60 pounds a
month because usually it's 10 of the
rent you're gonna have to pay for
maintenance on the property if something
but even though if the tenants break
something they'll fix it but usually i
allow 10 of the rent for maintenance and
and other stuff so let's say another 60
pounds so that's going to be 60 60 120
um
140 so 490 minus 140 means you'll be
left with around about 600 minus 140 is
going to be 460. so you're going to make
460 pounds
per month
you're going to make per year 460 times
12 around about
five thousand five hundred and twenty
pounds a year so you make an extra five
and a half thousand pounds per year
that's passive okay and you invested
to in order to make that five thousand
five hundred pounds per year you
invested how much well 17 and a half
thousand pounds of deposit
you're gonna have to pay stamp duty
which and solicitor fees maybe a little
like refurb but i'll tell you something
if you've got 30 000 pounds in the bank
good news is you're gonna have a whole
lot of change in your back pocket too
that is how if i was starting out with
thirty thousand pounds and i wanted to
buy buy step property that's how i'd go
about it i hope you found this video
helpful and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you